extraordinary things look hard candies
bold it's compressed into submission for
cancer
[Applause]
and leading the world take on the
exercise of climate change
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
teachers hold very reduction in the cost
of the gun or the college in your
student debt if you volunteer you pay
nothing
we can do this
let's get something straight Wall Street
in Berlin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
completion of burning buildings to
protect other people food block cars
pick up garbage that's better
[Applause]
a pathway for 11 million citizens why
don't you do that I don't get going
the I word to the steelworkers the
boredom is the flowers these are the
people that have forgotten I greet you
man the people jump forgot the people I
will never forgot that will always
remember folks that's what we need
economy rewards well everybody
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's why I was so proud yesterday a
race bike and go Charizard
no objection because of a rawr
and that's why that's why I'm so proud
so incredibly proud that encouraged both
on the penny doors by jadecloud bar
our campaign reflects the diversity of
this partying station and that's how it
should be because we need to bring
everybody along
[Music]
[Applause]
Democrat
[Applause]
the flames we are used as a sign of
weakness
you gotta believe that we were the
beacon of the world
we're all part of something bigger than
ourselves that's what I've said for the
glow of my candidacy not sowing seeds
and division and anger and hate we got a
beat down struck but we can't become
like him badly especially someone who
can heal
just like we did with passed Obamacare
what a President Obama mine did save the
American automobile others here what we
did and passed the pilot stage women I
and what's not enough it's just a start
we need the president can heal the
country as well and that is what I will
do your president
no results for you to progress English
for Robert Romney he said our reach
should exceed our grass and my reach
does exceed our grass being dumped out
of my mind we can grasp whatever we
reach for ladies and gentlemen let me
pull over the poet down second Sadie
we're going to talk about the character
here's what he says I believe this for
the bottom AHA DBT
he said history says don't hope on this
side of the grave but then once in a
long time the Lord
tidal wave of justice rises up and hope
and history rhyme we can make hope and
history rhyme
[Applause]
we are by the United States America
[Applause]
[Music]
we walked away from it ladies and
gentlemen I believe every fiber of my
being as we are again
[Applause]
God protect our troops
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]